you
be from indiana please unmute you are on
the air my friend hi can you hear me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making it only fans sorry if i if i've
done making an omelette what no no
making it only fans uh you know uh
gardening season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
in the name of jesus anything
that would be of an antichrist we break
it right now in the name of jesus every
antichrist spirit we break it right now
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus from
south america they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
[Music]
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus in
south america they're coming here
they're coming here
all strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike until
you have victory for every enemy that is
aligned against you let there be that we
would angels are being released right
now angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus in
south america they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
victory victory victory
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus from
south america they're coming
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be that we would strike
the ground for you will give us victory
god i hear a sound of abundance of rain
i hear a sound of victory i hear a sound
of shouting and singing i hear a sound
of
victory the will of man for the will of
god we override the will of man for the
will of god we over
rivals my bags of mangoes
i love mangoes too nine
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three by seeds
that's it
eight or eleven
[Music]
bring bucks mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
daughter wants me to be healthy
healthy daughter wants me to be healthy
if highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
all right welcome everybody i wish we
were meeting today under better
circumstances but sadly we are not we
have been completely cut out 100
from facebook monetization not for seven
days
not for 14 or 21 not even for 30 days
for 90 days we have been completely
banned from the facebook content
monetization program
oh man it is exhausting i will um i will
tell everybody about why momentarily
just gonna give it a minute for more
people to be able to connect etc etc
because i uh i only want to explain this
once
um and i will give you all of the
details that i have a freakadelic said
via super chat parkman
parkman you're really irresponsible you
were mia when the other spidermans were
tussling with doc ock and co recently
what the hell's the matter with you
man i don't even know
what they're talking about
i just have no idea thanks to olivia
julius for the beta membership over on
youtube i do appreciate that very much
also want to say thanks to dizzy bird
for the twitch prime subscription that
is number one today
um okay let should i just jump right
into what's going on with facebook i
know that there's going to be a lot of
people coming in later
not understanding what's going on
so maybe i'll just give it give it a
minute
chaka seki says i watched the one six
documentary on
oh i'm sorry hbo hbo
not hubbeau the footage was absolutely
chilling and brings home the true horror
of the day absolutely
no doubt about it
um
yeah
oh thanks to jen here for gifting five
subs i appreciate that i'm gonna jump in
in a moment david sir when you cut your
pinky finger was it using one of the
knives of the show sponsor no it
actually was not is it a testament to
their sharpness that's a good question
no it was not um i am as you can maybe
see
i after cutting off the tip of my finger
last week it is now
basically healed when i look at both
like this
one is round and one is flat across
which is to be perfectly frank it's a
little disturbing to see
but it's uh it's basically fine i'm not
using uh
i'm not using adhesive bandages anymore
some people call them band-aids
uh i call them adhesive bandages i
appreciate the concern andy though uh
thank you very very much
um okay listen i'll i'll just get right
into what's going on
so all right some how many people in the
chat have been with us since adpocalypse
adpocalypse was uh march 3 basically
march 30
march 30 2017
so that we can kind of get oriented how
many people in the chat have been with
the show that long
um looks like a bunch okay
those were tough times says greenman yes
yes it was a dark period in the show's
history okay not everybody a lot of
people have but not everybody so let me
let me explain what's going on
back in march of
2017 we experienced adpocalypse one what
we call apocalypse 1.0 and what this
happened was that i i believe it was
let me just be accurate
um
just for accuracy let me go to 2017
march i remember it as a weekend
exactly okay okay so here was the deal
on
we get youtube data two days delayed so
see if you can follow this
on the third of the month you get your
earnings from the first of them you
don't get them you get your data about
how much you made on the first of the
month on the fourth of the month you
find out how much you made on the second
of the month so let's do a little test
on the 27th of the month you get your
earnings data from the
from the
the 25th
beautiful you guys understand
on april
2nd 2017
i woke up sunday sunday morning getting
ready for the week how did we do last
week i pull up youtube revenue and
because it's april 2nd i got my data for
march 31st and it says we made
19 cents
19 cents
and i say
what the hell is going on here
we went from making money on youtube to
19 cents and then i go on my channel and
i see there's no ads running
i contact
secular talk host and now it's called
the kyle kelinski show secular then
secular talk host kyle kolinsky and i
say sir
what's happening and he goes i got hit
with the same thing
we later learned
that because of
an ad or two that played on a racist
video
youtube essentially shut off advertising
for almost all news and politics content
okay
this lasted for basically two weeks
where we made zero and ad revenue slowly
trickled back
over like the following
year
okay
and so at that point we were very
reliant on youtube revenue and so i
decided to diversify
that's why shortly after that we started
publishing all of our content to
facebook not just a clip or two it's why
we started doing the amazon affiliate
program we eventually started doing
tvitch
and growing our support there the idea
was
there's too much platform risk
with so much of our revenue tied up by
youtube when they went and shut it off
overnight
okay
unfortunately the platforms we
diversified to have also over time shut
off the siphon as many of you know we've
dealt with
at least two if not three twitch bands
where
once it was because we aired a debate
and cnn shut us down another time it was
because of a graphical gory element in
the kyle ridden house trial
there was a third one that now i don't
remember oh
one was a totally bogus takedown from
some scammers that didn't actually have
anything to do with us okay
good
so
we saw twitch go to zero but we're
diversified we're diversified okay good
we've also previously as you may
remember we took a seven day
monetization ban from facebook
we never found out why we were told
something you posted violated our t's
and c's terms and conditions
we never found out what
and after seven days our facebook's
revenue came back in
okay
today
we experienced basically
ad poc that one of those
uh
dewy
mornings where it's chilly and you get
up and you say all right we've got a new
week let's see what we did last week and
i saw that our facebook revenue went to
zero
not 19 cents
not
a dollar
it went to zero
what's going on
so i start investigating and i see that
we have lost monetization on facebook
for 90 days this is adpocalypse ii
the reckoning that's what we're calling
this nicely said
uh on twitch
this is adpocalypse 2 the reckoning
we're banned for 90 days why are we
banned
i have no idea it says click here to see
details of why you were banned i click i
click i click
nothing comes up it's just it glitched
glitched glitched glitched glitch
okay
eventually i talked to my team last week
pat was off on vacation so john was
handling the uploads and he said oh yeah
since i did the uploads
i got the notification
here is why we got a 90-day monetization
ban on facebook are you guys are people
ready i hope people are sitting down for
what i'm about to show you
oh people aren't ready okay well i'll
just wait
let me know when you're ready oh people
are ready okay
here's why we were banned
okay your post didn't follow our
community standards
this is a post okay
it's a post about our clip alex jones
loses his [ __ ] turns on trump this is
jones turning on trump because trump is
quote pro-vaccine
and this was our post about it will
trump's base draw the line at his
support for the vaccine alex jones loses
his [ __ ] turns on trump
okay
this is why we have lost 90 days of
monetization on facebook and you know
what because we decided to diversify
right
facebook
is now close to 20 of our revenue
gone for 90 days
now
we must be able to appeal it right
there's an appeal button
you can't type anything for all i know
it goes to a reviewer
who knows where in the in the world who
knows what their level of english
proficiency is who knows if they would
even understand that we are pro-vaccine
we are reporting on the conflict between
alex jones and trump over vaccination
right a lot of people saying i don't get
what the problem is
this does not violate their terms and
conditions now let me say something
right now
to every single person in the audience
who is a right-wing nut who's going to
write to me and they're going to go
david this is a taste of your own
medicine you've advocated censorship for
so long
and asked for this
and it's only a matter of time until
they were going to come for you the
globalists
and asura
okay
i 100
respect and recognize
that facebook has terms and conditions
and that they can enforce them
the problem here is we didn't violate
the terms and conditions
there is no way i know the terms and
conditions you can't do anti-vac stuff
or spread covet disinformation on
facebook and we didn't
okay so i am not taking issue with
facebook's right to say these are the
rules
and we're going to
enforce them
i am saying
the mechanism for enforcing this stuff
is garbage
it's pond scum
this used to be an issue on youtube
i've had many criticisms on youtube
where there was a period of time
where youtube's algorithm or logarithm
if you think back to you know the the
written house trial one food around noon
the algorithm on youtube used to be
unable to distinguish between white
supremacist content
and people criticizing white supremacy
right we used to criticize white suprema
i'm against white supremacy some of you
may know that
okay
and we used to
get hit with problems because youtube's
old algorithm
it's white supremacy we're banning it
whether it's pro or anti that's been
fixed fortunately
okay
so at the end of the day
we've appealed the appeals are like a
black hole on facebook i've reached out
to everyone i know i listened to this i
reached out to my youtube rep and said
listen i know you have nothing to do
with facebook but because you're in this
industry do you know anyone at facebook
because i don't know
um
i reached out to jenk
jenkyuger from the young turks thinking
you know they have a really large
presence on facebook maybe he knows
someone who could put me in touch
um we've done all of it but the most
likely scenario the most likely scenario
is we have lost twenty percent of our
revenue for the next nine weeks uh 90
days
that's the unfortunate reality so
we obviously
yeah we have to be ready to be
demonetized on any platform that's why
we diversify that's why we're on twitch
that's why we're on all these different
things
so
if anybody knows someone at facebook now
please do not flood my inbox with a link
to the form to contact facebook i'm
aware of that we did it they don't write
back doom if i'm saying this seriously
if you really know a person at facebook
that you could introduce me to via email
please email info davidpakman.com don't
send me the link for a support request
on facebook it's just that it no no okay
um now why is it so important for us to
fight this it's important to fight this
because facebook is littered with
disinformation and so if we go
because when you get demonetized the
content also gets de-prioritized because
it's considered dangerous you know
misinformation
if we go the problem gets worse on
facebook it becomes more of an echo
chamber we do have you know 250 000
followers and 150 000 likes on there so
it's an important platform for us so
that's why we're gonna fight it the best
we can so if you really know someone at
facebook
i would love it if you help me get in
touch
and honestly the the most important
thing that we can also do
is let's try to recover
the lost revenue okay so i have created
a coupon code the coupon code is f
facebook i'm not going to say anything
it's just it's facebook with two fs
facebook you go to joinpakman.com i say
do yearly i prefer yearly but you could
do either you hit sign up all right the
coupon code is f facebook whoops
f facebook two fs
um and you get a monster discount okay
yeah if
i would appreciate it stands for fun
facebook exactly it's so fun
it's so fun that's exactly what it uh
what it stands for so
that's basically the situation and uh i
i you know would appreciate people's
support to the extent that um
that they can they can do anything
but that's uh
that's what it is so we'll have an
update hopefully tomorrow
sorry let me see what's happening with
super chats danny says here's some help
for the monetization loss you're the
tops in my book thank you danny i
appreciate that also a really generous
50 super chat from tony who says i found
your show mr pacman through tyt and then
ring of fire and bo bo and mr dole thank
you all
thank you very much
um and also appreciate everybody uh
subscribing over on on twitch let me
make sure i'm thanking everybody
properly thanks to cosmos
sell prime lucy goosey not sure
lucy goosey also gifted five and
charistotle that puts that's 10 putting
us at 16.
uh really really really appreciate that
um
oh yeah what about tweeting listen
anything you guys can do please do so if
if you if there's some facebook twitter
support account and people want to start
tweeting at them
or submitting requests or whatever
anything people are willing to help with
i think is absolutely fine we we love
all of it okay
kb says f facebook yes exactly exactly
f facebook is the code today
and it is a really really powerful code
okay people asking about the the whether
the chess tournament is still going on
the chess tournament is going on okay
tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow yeah um you can
participate let me go to davidpakman.com
chess go to
davidpakman.com
joinmychessclub on chess.com it's free
i'm not selling you anything i want you
to support via membership but this is
free okay 6 p.m eastern tomorrow we're
doing a chess tournament it's open to
everybody
all skill levels
we're going to have people who have
basically never played before and we
will also have some grand masters
international masters etc i'm going to
update you on who is playing of note
number one
grand master benjamin feingold will be
playing in the tournament number two
international master eric rosen will be
playing in the tournament number three
international master levy rosman will be
playing in the tournament number four
uh hold on let me make sure i get
everybody's ranks correctly
um
women's international master jesse
february also a streamer from south
africa will be playing
um unfortunately anna kramling has had
to drop out she was going to play but
she's ultimately not going to be able to
but it's going to be really really great
it's going to be really really great so
the tournament will be at 6 00 pm
eastern time tomorrow
all you have to do now is join the chess
club at davidpakman.com
chess
and then tomorrow you will be able to
join the actual tournament okay so
that's what's going on couple other
super chats dustin says david you once
mentioned you grew up in belgium
i've been to belgium once in my life for
eight days no i i don't know anything
about that nicholas with a 99.99
super chat says keep it up david you
just be exhausted
janice says let's all chip in
nemo nova says i call it hate book it's
just one dumpster fire after another
consider it a badge of honor well folks
memberships are dumping in with the
coupon code michael kennison just signed
up on my website with the coupon code
obama
ellen lyons just signed up on my website
thank you ellen
larry riley just signed up with the code
f facebook
aaron saul is a new member
dan mallory has signed up
gabrielle barrera has signed up thanks
to todd johnson
and mark perez all signing up with the
coupon code
f facebook
very much appreciate that
rewatching your january 6 stream knowing
what was about to happen was such a
weird experience even then you couldn't
imagine the capital being breached well
said
hopper loves me all riled up okay
larry reilly says that's why i cancelled
facebook mira says sorry about the lost
income f facebook been a member since
2019. thank you
rebecca says i just deleted my facebook
should have done it years ago feels
great yeah it's a double-edged sword
because we don't want to leave facebook
to the bad guys only you know what i
mean
thanks to oximet and also jody b for
gifting six subscriptions i really
appreciate that
um tony uh sends a five dollar super
chat okay let's get into some other
stuff oh my oh wait a second hold on
memberships are dumping in
thanks to louis bird for signing up with
the coupon code f facebook big massive
dumps
uh mitchell beatty has just signed up
olivia cuppage
mr moseley is a new member
natalie turner jones dumps
that puts us at 35 i really appreciate
that
uh wow and super chats are just flying
in
f facebook it's the new populist anthem
sir i heard you something like growing
up in belgium was really confused but
thought nothing of it listen guys i have
never claimed to have grown up in
belgium i was born in argentina okay
susan comment has signed up with the
coupon code f facebook kyle wise is a
new member and so is samir mara putting
us at 38. they call them dumps
jamal swift happy new year homie how are
you feeling what are some of your 2022
goals well
in the immediate to get this whole thing
uh fixed up
uh
let's see what else we've got here oh i
just got a message
from craig and craig says david i work
at facebook and can try to submit a
request
now we're talking
now we're talking let's let's get that
going okay very good
um
i am willing to provide my long-form
birth certificate just to prove that we
did not violate any facebook rules i
would be willing to do that
yeah
oh also thanks to philip bressi for
signing up on my website with the coupon
code f facebook
um
keep up the good work
colin says we belgians stick together
hey you know what in the interests of uh
unity
and collegiality
i will consider myself an honorary
belgian i'm already a member in twitch
sub can we get an uncharged pickles
absolutely i am glad to drop that in
uncharged piccolos very well said just
dropping a small dump super chat oh my
god
let's ban facebook from the david pakman
show i know it means lost revenue and
i'm sorry about that
ray says f facebook
wow that code is really taken off
dale pope
has just signed up using the code and so
has steve bosley all right let me get to
some more of the content memberships are
just dumping in at such a rapid pace
but i do want to get into the content
all right let's start with a few things
i want your help interpreting this was
posted to the to the subreddit
it says david pronouncing anything other
than the word slash i sleep david
pronouncing the word slash real [ __ ] i
don't know what this means is this when
i go like
oh yeah well you know i was just sitting
there and uh it was a beautiful day and
nothing really happened but then all of
a sudden it got sunny slash snowing
and like is that what people mean i'm
not even sure what that is
okay nobody else knows either slash
here's another one i'll actually like
reading this one my favorite pacmanisms
i love the term the trump riots that's
not even a joke to me i mean that's just
what they are
and trump on trump violence they are
succinct and funny
fox news propagandist tucker carlson
someone else likes
my favorite is referring to mike lindell
as simply pillow gets me every time
something about the way it's delivered
with such dryness as though it were his
actual name dumps massive dumps strong i
don't know whenever he uses strong or
strongly i can't help but smirk it's
just a funny gag to me yeah it is
looking at that very strongly right
all right
so there's a nice element um i told you
last week
how a lot of the maggas were
oh you got to be kidding me
someone on twitch is saying make your
own site instead of being a leech on
youtube facebook and twitch i i did make
my own site it's called davidpakman.com
that's that's why i'm saying to people
when you sign up on my site we don't
have to deal with all of the
demonetization like that that's what i'm
talking about
we're we're trying not to rely on these
platforms that's exactly what i'm saying
oh i think we got a ban is this a ban
yeah we're banning
get the hell out of here get off my
stream
what's that movie uh air force one where
uh
harrison ford says get off my plane
just get off my stream please go away
um
okay
all right let's so so listen let's let's
get back this
last week i played for you a video of a
magat
turning on trump we did a clip on it it
got 600 000 views this is a reminder of
one magat turning on trump
hey donald trump this is daniel mccarthy
in arizona the world is waking up to
your massive grift please stop with the
smoke and mirrors with these audits stop
with your fundraising stop uh
establishment candidate endorsements
stop pushing this gene therapy the sauce
i hear you're coming to florence arizona
for another one of your do nothing
rah-rah sessions
this guy it's so funny because this
guy's so toxic but he is right that
trump is running a grift and the the
rallies are do nothing rah-rah events
that's all true
but also like this guy's a complete
lunatic republican
and the vaccines are not gene therapies
i have an offer for you i will give one
million dollars to the charity of your
choice
if you take 30 minutes of your stage
time on january 15th
and debate me or answer my questions
even in front of your crowd think about
all the things that you've done that
you've got you've not been held
accountable for right you ushered in
medical tyranny you exploded our
national debt true you relinquished our
sovereignty with the usmca trade deal
false you passed more gun laws than
obama did with fixed nick's unclear
warned about election fraud but yet you
did nothing to prevent it even after my
team months in advance warned you after
we were stolen from in the senate
primary you gave up on therapeutics and
you push an experimental gene therapy
false people are literally dying because
of their trust in you you enacted the
lockdowns and you surrounded yourself
with swamp creatures for four years
false and then true the january 6
protesters that came down to the capital
you set them up those people are being
treated worse than dogs now and these
are your most loyal supporters they
treated him like a dog trump you failed
america you're the most deceptive
president in american history that's
true that's absolutely true and trust me
there's been a lot of psyops before
that's fine i posted the terms and
conditions of my 1 million dollar offer
to my website www.demanddaniel.com
i look forward to seeing you on january
15th although this isn't brendan fraser
isn't it no you won't do it because
you're a little [ __ ] true
check this out look at this alpha
behavior
[Music]
okay so we looked at that last week this
guy is not letting up i've got a new
clip from this guy check this out these
people are continuing
let them fight the strategy is let them
fight
so i want to make it clear to all you
people out there that are potentially
watching this that are you know kind of
haters in regards to oh yeah oh trump
would oh trump's uh part of a master
operation or some some uh 4d chess or
any of that nonsense no trump is a fraud
that's true that's absolutely true
you were frauded and it's time to move
on quickly this guy's a sham and it's
time to expose him as a sham and move on
what i love about this is that
even radical republican lunatics like
this guy are completely correct they've
suddenly he's it's like yes
trump is a fraud he is a sham and the
infighting is just delightful
uh and potentially he should be held
accountable like the rest of these
criminals yeah that have perpetrated
this fraud on the american people yes
yes exactly
so um
we've got a we've got a
you know anything we can do to foment
this type of insanity we should try to
do
we should try to do
uh oh man i have fallen way behind on
stuff i want to say thanks to mad city
miss kitty as well as dragonfly back
home for the twitch subs putting us at
43
huge subscription dumps happening on my
website i want to say thanks to felix
beaulieu
for signing up with the coupon code f
facebook
zachary brown is a new member maria
rayna has signed up
tugs mccowan is a new member
anthony montecalvo has signed up
achal oza is a new member thanks to ben
harris and scott ellis for the
memberships
iretina agalapal as well as will sherman
have signed up that puts us at 53.
53. big massive dumps
the coupon code is f facebook
and you can scroll back to see what's
going on
um other super chats coming in
um
got these
abc
facebook says powerstorm via super chat
thank you so much i appreciate that
also thanks to longhair kev for the
twitch prime
you are number 54 today
what a day
what a day
and uh
an insane insane situation all right
let's continue with the content here
uh anybody want to drink their own urine
well
christopher key
believes urine therapy
may be the antidote
to
the virus
here is christopher key now going full
delusions
with
elements of urine and urea apparently
the antidote that we've seen now and we
have tons and tons of research
is
does he have a baby or a microphone in
his jacket i can't tell what's in there
you're in therapy
okay
and i know to a lot of you
a lot of you this sounds crazy yeah yes
yes it does sound crazy that's true
guys god's given us everything we need
okay
and i'm gonna give you again
i test and prove all things okay
um
this has been around for centuries um
we've got urine has been around longer
than centuries i hate to break it to
christopher keys research after research
documented peer-reviewed published
papers on your end we do
yes there are published papers on urine
that's true right like the field of
urology regularly publishes paper
related to urine they don't say it
treats or cures covid so i did a little
bit of research um the urine stuff
some you know
this guy does look like the type of guy
that would be collecting his own urine
um
there's sometimes uh mental illness
where people end up collecting their own
waste and it's
it's a it's a condition to be dealt with
on its own it's a serious condition
but
this has been kind of like a repeated
thing where some people talk about
uh you should neti pot urine and then
it'll clear your sinuses or use it on
your skin to treat
who the hell knows what or whatever
it's all bogus
it's all completely bogus
there's only one thing
that i've read
that urine can help with on a very
temporary basis okay and i want to be
really really careful here
if you are dehydrated to the point of
almost dying
drinking your own urine for one or maybe
two days
might get you to survive just a little
bit longer so that you can be rescued
okay
if you do it it's urine is 95 water the
other five percent is stuff your kidneys
are filtering out so i actually looked
i'm going to cover this tomorrow i
looked at the peer-reviewed research
if you do the urine drinking for too too
long
you're basically concentrating in your
kidneys the stuff that the kidneys are
removing
and it's very very bad so
absolute best case absolute best case
a day or two
drinking your own urine can replenish
some of the water that you've lost in a
dream in a
catastrophic dehydration situation if
you've read the book i don't remember if
it i think it's called 437 days
about the fisherman salvador alvarenga
who drifted off the coast of mexico and
ended up in the south pacific
for brief periods he drank his own urine
but it was not how he survived 437 days
he very quickly figured out how to
collect rain water
okay
um
anyway
so that's the truth
about drinking your own urine dear god
these people are really something else
um thanks to france staring for signing
up on my website with the code f
facebook
kimberly kelberg has signed up on my
website and anthony foglia oh sorry and
also wanda fuller
putting us at 58. really appreciate
everybody coming out in support um
given what's taking place
over on the uh over on the facebook all
right let's now get into
this completely wacky tucker carlson
interview tucker carlson completely
cucked ted cruz now some of you find
that that phrase that term
uh graphic and inappropriate it it is a
proverbial cucking but it is a cucking
nonetheless um let's take a look at it
so we played this tape for you last time
we were surprised by it we prefaced it
by saying every conservative appreciates
ted cruz because he's one of the
smartest and most articulate people in
the congress
[Laughter]
but he referred publicly to what
happened on january 6 is quote a violent
terror attack here it is yeah
we are approaching a solemn anniversary
this week
and it is an anniversary of a violent
terrorist attack on the capitol where we
saw the men and women of law enforcement
demonstrate incredible courage
incredible bravery
risk their lives it's actually the rare
sensible statement from ted cruz and he
ends up having to go and grovel to
tucker to defend the men and women who
serve in this capital
senator cruz was game enough to come on
tonight we appreciate that he joins us
now senator thanks so much for coming on
so i guess what i mean there are a lot
of dumb people in the congress yes yes
yes exactly you're not one of them i
think you're smarter than i am
and you never use words
carelessly this is legendary cuckoldry
and yet you called this a terror attack
when by no definition was it a terror
attack that's a lie
you told that lie on purpose and i'm
wondering why you did
oh man it mat
this is incredible
well tucker thank you for having me on
when you aired your episode last night i
sent you a text shortly thereafter and
said listen i'd like to go on because
please let me go on and apologize
please tucker don't blacklist me i'll
say i'm sorry the way i phrased things
yesterday it was sloppy and and it was
frankly dumb and i don't buy them
i know by that far look i've known you a
long time since before you went to the
senate you're a supreme court contender
you take words as seriously as any man
who's ever served in the senate and
every word you repeated that phrase i do
not believe that you use that
accidentally i just don't
it's so tucker as a result of my sloppy
phrasing it's caused a lot of people to
misunderstand what i meant let me tell
you what what i meant to say right what
i was referring to are are the limited
number of people who engaged in violent
attacks against police officers i think
you and i both agree that if you assault
a police officer you should go to jail
sure that's who i was talking about and
the reason the phrasing was sloppy is i
have talked dozens if not hundreds of
times i've drawn a distinction i wasn't
saying that the thousands of peaceful
protesters supporting donald trump are
somehow terrorists i wasn't saying the
millions of of patriots across the
country supporting president trump are
terrorists and that's what a lot of
people have misunderstood that wait a
second but even your way but hold on
what you just said doesn't make sense so
if somebody assaults a cop he should be
charged and go to jail i couldn't agree
more we have said that for years
but that person's still not a terrorist
how many people have been charged with
terrorism now that's really a red
herring because very often
in events that we would all agree were
terrorist events it's common that by the
time you get to charges the charges
aren't for literal terrorism that's
that's very very common in fact
i think at this well let me not say
there's there's there's even more detail
to look at when you're considering state
charges as to what it even means to be
charged for terrorism i don't want to
get into it because i'm not exact i
don't have the information in front of
me but it that doesn't really tell us
much
on january 6th like why'd you use that
word you're playing into the other
side's
characterization that as joe kent just
explained allows them to define an
entire population as foreign combatants
and you know that so why'd you do it so
tucker let me answer you directly the
reason i use that word for a decade i
have referred to people who violently
assault police officers as terrorists
i've done so over and over and over
again if you look at all the assaults
we've seen across the country i've
called that terrorism over and over
again that being said tucker i agree
with you it was a mistake to say that
yesterday i was a bad bad boy
and the reason is what you just said
which is we've now had a year of
democrats in the media twisting words
and trying to say that all of us are
terrorists trying to say you're a
terrorist i'm a terrorist like what does
this have to do with what he said this
this is crazy
and so look i don't like people who who
assault cops and and i
stand up and defend cops
and
the reason i use that word is that's the
word i've always used for people that
violently attack cops but in this
context i get why people were angry
because we've had a year tucker don't
you see he's groveling and apologizing
let the guy do it with his dignity the
corrupt corporate media and democrats
claiming anyone who who objected to to
the election fraud and by the way
remember what was happening
can i just ask hold on you work in this
i just i guess i just don't believe you
and i mean that with respect because i
have such respect
for your acuity this is tough love this
is this is daddy doing tough love on his
son
because he's got to teach him
you can't do your games in the senate
anymore ted and your precision and i've
seen it on display i've covered you as a
reporter i know how you speak
and you have sat there for a year and
watched people use language to distort
the events of that day
intentionally insurrection
of course terrorism
saying it's an insurrection is a
political term it's a lie it's sort of
like literally the definition of
insurrection i've repeatedly denounced
it and and when it comes to
ted cruz has denounced calling it an
insurrection much more than he's
denounced the actual insurrection look i
was focusing on what i normally say that
what you aired was a little 15 second
snippet what i normally say is violence
is wrong peaceful protest is right if
you engage in violence you should be
prosecuted if you're speaking you have a
right to speak i say that all the time
and i agree
so who's ray epps by the way since you
are a senator like there he and this
other guy are clearly encouraging the
crowd
to commit crimes
either one has been arrested or charged
what is that do you think so i think
that is a very good question i don't
know who ray epps is i've seen that
video multiple times it's so let me talk
about let's do the ray epps
oh man i wasn't even gonna do this but
they're doing it
um
let me see what we've got here
okay let me let me tell you about ray
epps all right uh
oh god they want me to disable ads i
guess i'll do it
okay who oh my god that's why i have ads
on uh turned off who is ray epps the
conspiratorial claim that the attack on
the u.s capitol was a false flag
conducted by federal agents hinges
largely on the identity of one man okay
on january 5th
a man was filmed encouraging people to
go peacefully to the capitol the
following day
video didn't make much noise at the time
but in the ensuing weeks this person
identified as ray epps became a central
figure in a conspiracy theory claiming
the federal agents provoked the attack
on the capital which prompted readers to
search for information about him on
snopes
so who is ray epps is he a federal agent
is there evidence to support these
claims
epps is the owner of the naughty barn
a wedding and event venue in queen creek
arizona
according to the daily mail he's 60 and
a retired u.s marine
epps is also a trump supporter and
appears to have long-running ties to the
oath keepers a far-right anti-government
militia that formed shortly after the
election of obama epps is listed as the
president of the arizona chapter of the
oath keepers wizep's at the capitol on
january 6th epps told arizona central he
did travel to dc for stop the steal
photos have captured him in the area the
night before he's telling a crowd go
into the capitol he said i'm going to
put it out there i'll probably go to
jail for it tomorrow we need to go into
the capitol peaceably peacefully we are
freedom we are peaceful that's what it's
about it's not about hurting people
as he makes these remarks people can be
heard chanting fed
here's the video
so i'm going to put it out there i'm
probably going to go to jail for it
tomorrow
we need to go into the capitol
into the capital
[Applause]
okay good
is epps a federal agent
there is no evidence to indicate eps as
a federal agent or was working with the
government claims to that effect are
based largely on the fact that he wasn't
arrested
the argument goes epps who can be seen
encouraging people to go to the capitol
escaped prosecution because supposedly
he's a federal agent in the above
displayed video according to the
conspiracy epps made the statements on
behalf of the government to encourage
trump supporters to storm the capital so
they could be arrested but there's a
much simpler explanation as of this
writing the u.s department of justice
and fbi have arrested more than 725
people for their involvement in the
capital attack they focused on
individuals who unlawfully entered the
capitol building as of this writing
there's no indication epps made his way
into the capital when asked about his
comments he told azcentral i didn't do
anything wrong
the only thing that meant is we could go
in the doors like everyone else it was
totally totally wrong the way they went
in
from the footage available it appears
epps was at the rally but he didn't go
into the capital or engage in violence
one video actually shows epps trying to
de-escalate a fight and here is that
video
i would have came locked and loaded if i
knew this was happening take a step back
take a step back we're holding ground
we're not trying to get people hurt
they don't want to get hurt you don't
want to get hurt
back up
so that's that's that's the whole story
um
the investigation's not over that could
change was epps once listed on the list
of suspects in the days following the
attack the fbi released a series of
videos and photographs as help
identifying people a photograph
appearing to show epps was included in
one of the first batches of images
this is eps here in the bottom left
as of this writing it was no longer on
the website some have claimed it's more
proof he was an undercover fbi agent
it could be just as reasonable that they
decide they realized he didn't actually
go you know and commit any crime so
we're not looking at him so it's an
assertion and there is not actually any
evidence for it all right let's watch a
little more of this disturbing he's
clearly urging the crowd to violate the
law when you see the crowd start
chanting fed fed fed for him to appear
on the fbi's most wanted list and come
off it's certainly
and correct me if i'm wrong it was not
the fbi's most wanted list right it was
just the seeking information
like even that's a that's that's a
literal lie from ted cruz these are
seeking unwanted seeking information
he wasn't on the top ten most wanted
makes it sound like he was up there with
bin laden
yes he was working for the fbi that's
not conclusive but that's the obvious
implication there's no evidence of that
there's no evidence of that so
ted cruz
seemingly to get back in tucker
carlson's good graces after being
brutally cucked
uh
starts just jumping in and saying of
course tucker your conspiracy theories
look like they're very very accurate
very very accurate
all right so that's that i want to say
thanks to baby deluxe both for signing
up and gifting a subscription on twitch
putting us at 60.
also want to say thank you to more
people continuing to dump in website
memberships lawson roberts just signed
up with the code
obama
brita n signed up with the code f
facebook joe galdo signed up with the
codef facebook scott van cleave is a new
member
thanks to andy bunnell and sandra
anderson
also mark onstad and danny thompson have
signed up putting us at 68
over in super chats
uh no it doesn't look like i have any
new super chats that's okay
and also a big thank you to cairus court
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code
you are new member number
uh okay let's continue
uh wait not this oh this is just newsmax
um oh yeah i had a couple other video
clips to look at i don't know if this is
new i hadn't seen this but this is it
was posted today another mission
michigan mom freaks out at the school
board
over the secret society
conspiracy let's see what this is about
transparency in this board needs to
happen the secret societies need to stop
because you're wearing your red shoes
you got blood on your feet you got blood
on your hands
and it's ridiculous you say we the
people we are the people and when we the
people come together it's going against
you guys
i don't know what she's talking about
seems
pretty pretty bonkers
oh thanks to captain smiles for gifting
five subs on twitch today i really
appreciate that also thank you to
richard selig for signing up with the
coupon code
f
facebook
let's continue couple other things for
you guys
this is i guess another woman
refusing to wear a mask a bunch of you
sent me this one i have not seen it
let's take a look please leave our store
if you don't want him asking you please
leave
you said you were going to show me this
ma'am
please leave it is against the law you
are not afraid i guess i i guess it's
against the law can you please leave you
don't want to wear a mask right here why
did you suddenly get emotional
ma'am why do i have to i'm not trying to
have a conversation with you anymore i'm
asking you to leave and then all of a
sudden you got worked up can you please
leave man can you please leave your name
my name is right here in my position
right there can you please leave
let me take a picture yeah you can all
you want to please leave this evie says
it on the door ma'am wear a mask
[Music]
you can of course
oops it's foggy
i can write it down a piece of paper for
you want me to it's foggy
it's just a simple picture
now that you're taking a picture can you
please leave
[Music]
well it's hard to read would you write
it on a paper for me please ma'am you
are making this harder it has to be it's
just a simple thing it's been two years
of wearing a mask it is two years it is
regardless of how you feel it's it's our
company we're allowed to do it
i have my vaccination too but at the end
of the day ma'am
i don't really care man it's like it's
just the guy just works there you know
at the end of the day at the door says
please wear them out
the law means what it our business call
the police it's also weird that after
this long any of them still think a
business can't have as a policy that you
got to wear a mask like it's it's
shocking to even make the legal argument
at this point in time can you just leave
why you wanna why do you want the police
why are you afraid of calling the police
i'm not afraid to call them police just
leave because they're sworn to protect
our constitution the constitution does
protect my right to come to this place
if you need me to show you the sign on
the door now if you put this on facebook
you're gonna do what you will be
breaking i won't be what is she talking
about they both know it's being recorded
freaking a lot i've actually believed
it just passed i'm sure it is it is you
can take photos of me but you can't go
outing people on social media
that's completely untrue
completely untrue well i guess they
won't happen
look man
man
not that i'd be embarrassed by you
posting this because obviously i'm
completely in the right but you would be
committing a crime if you did post it
why am i bringing that up oh no no no
reason i'm sure i'm going to look great
from this please please
please
if you want to wear a mask then get a
mask if you don't want to wear a mask
or if you just let me purchase the food
unfortunately i can't let your person
fool you personally without a match up
here
then why can't you leave well i just
made that statement that you don't want
to leave nicely to me
can you please leave our store man yes i
will thank you very much and i hope you
learned that i didn't learn anything
goodbye
it's very common that they need to feel
like they ultimately were in control and
the way she decided once it was clearly
not going to go anywhere that she was
ready to leave by saving face was
she told him to ask nicely
so she feels like ultimately she was in
charge
he wasn't being nice once she told him
to be nice he did it and so she won and
she gets to leave this is the psychology
of these people it's really wild
danny says i just signed up for my
second website membership
better for you than this super chat glad
to know the website will accept more
than one membership oh one remember
former producer lewis he had 150 000
website memberships it was crazy it was
really really crazy
ping tick has signed up via twitch prime
and is number 76
i also want to say thanks to skittlestu
for gifting five subs putting us at 81
and then a huge thank you to desiree de
long
and
no thank you
no thank you for signing up using the
coupon code f facebook putting us at 83.
tony d dropping in a 20 super chat which
i very much appreciate as well all right
let's continue our tour of crazy here is
another on the plane incident another on
the plane incident this one was posted
yesterday i don't think i have seen this
one let's take a look at it together
so no mask and it looks like they're
trying to get this guy off the plane
oh i think we have seen this one before
actually
i think i've seen this one i think it
pans to a woman that's with him too do
you understand that
you made me like four goddamn hours he
gave me one top sucking warning one
warning that's it look the second he
said something
the second he said something i pulled it
over my nose
no give me my [ __ ]
give me my [ __ ]
give it to me
i don't think i've actually seen this
much of it i've seen like a 30 second
clip
for two seconds
[Music]
can you
hey guys i think this is mass formation
psychosis i think we finally found it
it wasn't good enough
like why is her mask even off now i
don't even understand like
why is the mask now off
it is like there's two freak outs going
on at the same time it's really weird
i wish i could be a fly on the wall
where these people who go we're not
worried we're gonna sue the hell out of
jetblue i would love to see the meetings
with attorneys
um
i have a friend who's who's an attorney
uh you know there's some attorneys that
will work on unlike a big
sometimes attorneys will work on a
contingency so you know they might get
like 30 of the settlement but those are
like very specific situations i have a
couple friends who are lawyers who have
people come to them who are a little
wacky and they go i want to sue this
person i want to sue that person i want
to see that person and his move instead
of ever saying that would be a [ __ ]
lawsuit that you would never win
his line is
we're a private law firm
um and so
this is something we'd be glad to start
researching for you
and uh understanding the situation
we charge 350 an hour and we're gonna
need
you know a five thousand dollar retainer
and they go away every single time every
single time that's that's
multiple lawyers who are friends of mine
say that's their move they never tell
someone this is not something you could
conceivably win also they probably
couldn't necessarily say that
definitively but they just go great
i think i understand the situation
we're a private law firm to start
looking into this we're going to need uh
five grand
and we charge 350 an hour 450 and you
know what we're depending on where where
they live and
and these people just go away
everyone i know is an attorney
did you say i'm bacardi
of course of course everyone you know is
returning
popcorn
what chaos what chaos
man it is really a it it is a mess out
there it is a complete and total mess
all right other super chats are coming
in claudia says love your show thank you
i appreciate that
in germany it's illegal to post pictures
or videos without someone's permission
because of privacy even if the person
knows they are recorded yeah in the us
if it's happening in in public
um
you you can post it
hey fams delete your facebook's y'all
says tyler i want to say a huge thank
you oh my god i can't even believe how
many people are signing up here
brian reeves is a new member on my
website
tom skirvin has just signed up
satish vermaraju is a new member
nigel jude saint john big massive dumps
i want to say thanks to robin lawson for
using the code f facebook dumps
and christian rosenblatt they call them
dumps has signed up as well that's six
putting us at 89
89.
uh i really really appreciate that if
you are wondering what is going on with
facebook i did a half hour about it at
the top of the stream
okay so i'm not gonna go back to it
right now just go back i'm not gonna do
it again
uh oh and also thank you to andrew
warren for signing up with the code
obama
obama
that is number 90. here's what's coming
up this week tomorrow 6 p.m eastern is
the chess tournament free
open to all just go to davidpakman.com
and get yourself signed up for free to
our chess club tomorrow the tournament
will go live at 6 p.m eastern i will be
streaming a bunch of other chess
streamers are playing it's open to all
it's free it's just a community event
saturday we'll be carrying the
michael flynn event at which trump will
be speaking trump expected to make some
kind of announcement what it will be i
don't know
um but that's going to be saturday i
don't yet know at what time
so that's upcoming and
i almost certainly
will do an additional stream tomorrow
before the chess stream
uh
because i expect that there's going to
be a lot a lot a lot going on philip
says all of these people want to feel
there's a conspiracy and they crack the
code it lets them think that they're
intelligent that leads to dunning-kruger
well said
and kt
says keep up the excellent work i
appreciate that
also want to say thanks to ellen wallace
who just signed up with the coupon code
facebook
at joinpakman.com
okay that's all i've got for today
everybody thank you for joining me we'll
be back tomorrow with the chess
tournament probably a second stream
we've got clips we have all sorts of
other stuff still publishing today and
then we got the trump rally on saturday
and so many other things i believe
tomorrow we're gonna have a biden speech
as well
so thank you for joining me we're gonna
be back so soon it'll be like i never
went off the air
you